le rapport public annuel de la Cour des
comptes pointe une situation des
finances publiques en 2023 parmi les
plus dégradés de la zone euro monsieur
le ministre nous ne pouvons plus
continuer dans cette voie la cour vous
exhorte à plus de responsabilités
budgétaire sans laquelle vous
précipiterez la France dans un gouffre
donnant nous pourrons nous extraire
notre souveraineté est en péril la
Commission européenne juge ainsi élevée
le risque pour la soutenabilité de notre
dette à moyen terme elle dépassera 111%
du produit intérieur brut à la fin de
l'année l'année 2023 devait sonner la
fin du quoi qu'il en coûte or les
mesures prises pour amortir le choc
inflationniste continueront de peser à
hauteur de 36 milliards d'euros sur la
dépense vous persistez dans cette
politique du carnet de chèques qui
consiste à déployer un catalogue de
mesures mal ciblées et donc trop peu
coûteuse
à 58% du PIB la France allait dépenses
publiques les plus élevées de la zone
euro pour des services publics toujours
moins efficaces parallèlement les
dépenses hors crise continuent de
s'envoler plus 3,5 en volume pour 2022
hors inflation monsieur le ministre nous
décrochons sur tous les fronts et vous
regardez ailleurs leur redressement de
la trajectoire est impératif est
nécessitera une détermination publique
politique dont vous n'avez jamais fait
preuve depuis 2017
qu'arrivera-t-il lorsque nous nous
retrouvons au côté de la Grèce ou de
l'Italie et de l'Italie dans le trio de
dettes des pays les plus endettés de la
zone euro